alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines on retourne aux bases le même
spot qui va à la chasse perd sa place on
aurait dû rester
lundi c'est la journée des drogues
illicit donc on va pas spécialement en
parler parce que c'est illicite et que
c'est interdit mais vendredi c'est la
journée olympique donc on va parler
sport et si on parlait sport ce weekend
on va voir s'il y a des potentiels parmi
vous
en ce moment il y a un peu d'orage c'est
dommage comme un ouragan
bonjour Chef comment vous appelez bien
Philippe bonjour Philippe bonjour
Est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
weekend c'est la journée olympique oui
des Jeux Olympiques
est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
week-end c'est la journée olympique ma
foi noire bon pourquoi pas mais les Jeux
Olympiques on en parle un peu beaucoup
trop on est d'accord
pas trop déçu que la pétanque soit aux
JO monsieur
je m'en contente
on peut vous poser une petite question
comment vous appelez monsieur
vous saviez que ce weekend c'est la
journée olympique du tout et bah avec
plaisir de vous la prendre ok ça marche
pas tout à l'heure bonjour
sachez que ce week-end c'est la journée
olympique
vous pratiquez un sport lequel non pas
du tout du tout c'est dommage parce que
là on voit il y a un certain profil oui
peut-être mais j'essaye de le pas perdre
de trop la forme est-ce que vous avez un
sport de prédilection là
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme comme
espoir de médaille
l'espoir de médaille
alors
vous jouez pas
je j'aurais pas pour les jeux ah bon
on peut se retrouver au 19 non
c'est le coup le coup à boire après le
parcours vous avez une passion un peu
sportive
non plus pour l'instant c'était la
course la course la course
est-ce que vous vous seriez vu en tant
que sportif par hasard
j'en ai fait un bout de temps ok c'est
quoi le poste technique
[Musique]
c'est quoi votre sport vous pour les
jeux
vous visez le podium quand même sur le
skate
alors est-ce que vous visez une médaille
déjà
ça veut dire est-ce que moi je vais
courir pour le podium
[Rires]
là si vous pouviez ce serait quel sport
là si je pouvais la reine des prés
j'ai mal au coude
comme ça on fixe le gardien et on tourne
le poignet comme il faut d'un effet au
ballon qui retourne dans le véto allez
là là il est dans la tout à fait dedans
est où les 10 secondes vous les avez là
de ma force j'ai une dessin d'épaule en
dessous des 12 des 12 secondes au 100
ouais vous allez en faire quoi de la
médaille ah bah écoutez je vais la
mettre dans un cadre il a raison dans
quelle pièce de la maison vous mettriez
une médaille de olympique là pour tout
le monde la voit
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]